today i have
professor monty winslow with me and dr
winslow grew up in canada
and received his undergraduate degree
from the university of victoria in
canada
he did his phd studies in immunology
working with
dr jerry crabtree at stanford university
before pursuing his post-doctoral
training with dr tyler jacks at mit
dr winslow is currently an associate
professor of genetics
and pathology at stanford university
the dr winslow's research focuses on
understanding the mechanisms that drive
cancer development progression
metastasis
and therapy response he's developed in
vivo mouse models that enable
the isolation and genomic
characterization of cancer cells
and use these models to contribute to
our understanding of cancer initiation
growth and progression these studies
have focused on
uncovering the molecular forces that
contribute to
the development and progression of the
three most metastatic
and deadly cancer types lung
adenocarcinoma
small cell lung cancer and pancreatic
cancer
he's also contributed to the development
of novel cancer modeling approaches
that enable rapid and quantitative
analyses
of the genetic drivers of carcinogenesis
his laboratory has generated methods for
somatic
crispr cas9 mediated genome editing and
used these models to introduce
both gain and loss of function
alterations
in somatic cells in vivo by
incorporating increasingly quantitative
methods and powerful in vivo methods
dr winslow's work in uncovering general
rules that govern tumor
isolation growth and progression
um excuse me dr winslow's work is
uncovering general rules
that govern tumor isolation
growth and progression across diverse
tumor genotypes
so thank you for being here and now i'll
pass it over to dr winslow
all right thank you jan for that uh
introduction and and thank you everyone
who's joined this webinar
what i want to do today is really um
give sort of a broad introduction of
you know how we and others have been
using crispr
genome editing to really understand
cancer better
so what i want to do is really three
things today i want to introduce
cancer genetics to you i want to
introduce genome editing
i'm going to then talk about some
applications of how
genome editing has contributed to our
better understanding of how cancer works
and then i'll kind of end with some
future directions where do i see this
going and some
sort of simple take-home messages from
this webinar today
first we'll talk about sort of cancer
genetics and genome editing
so despite there being other uh huge
global health problems right now um
cancer remains a tremendous um
tremendously high in incidence and
drives a lot of mortality around the
world this is sort of
just showing the metrics of the number
of
people who get different cancer types
and die from different different cancer
types worldwide
each year with lung colon cancer stomach
liver
breast cancer pancreatic cancer is is
right kind of
coming up next so cancer remains a kind
of a formidable disease
around the world but i want to show this
next plot because
despite the prevalence of cancer you
know in the united states and the world
we've actually made
pretty good progress over the last 50
years so what this chart is showing you
is
on the bottom axis is essentially well
let's let's look at the left-hand axis
first this is a metric that sometimes
people think about which is the 10-year
survival rate if a patient is diagnosed
with a certain cancer type
what's the chance they're going to be
alive 10 years later and you can see
that
you know different cancers have have
sort of different 10-year survivals
but i was going to say the important
thing is on this axis on the bottom
which is like
how much has that percent 10-year
survival change in the last 50 years so
for example if you look
i'm sort of at the top right you'll see
prostate cancer
you know there's more than a 50 percent
increase
in how long people survive with prostate
cancer what percent of people will
survive
10 years so for many of these cancers
that are moving to the right there's
been great advances in treatment
but there is some that remain down you
know at the bottom left lung cancer
pancreas cancer these are still
extremely hard to treat and where i
think we need
um really new advances
so cancer is fundamentally a genetic
disease and what this means is that
within the genome of the cells
of the normal cells that become cancer
there are
alterations that occur and that's those
alterations
that really initiate cancer and drive
cancer progression
these different type of alterations that
can occur in the genome they might be
mutations this means that there's a
single
you know letters in the genome single we
call them nucleotides that get changed
there can be structural alterations
there can be whole big pieces of
chromosomes that get stuck to each other
or
or flip around and there can also be
extra numbers of chromosomes
so these um maybe uh you know we get
three copies of certain chromosomes and
for some reason this helps drive
cancer so regardless of what these
alterations are there's really
three outcomes that you can get the
alteration the genomic change can either
essentially inactivate the gene that it
occurs in
and the reason that this can cause
cancer is maybe these are genes that
normally stop cells from
from growing now if you lose that gene
they might grow more
those alterations can increase the
activity
of that protein usually we call these
oncogenes you get a mutation and it
turns something on that really drives
the cell to now become
in rare cases they can act these
alterations can completely alter the
function of a gene
but so there's a relatively simple
relationship here genomic alterations
can drive these changes in your normal
cells
that can then lead to cancer
but it's despite the sort of simplicity
of that there's there's many
complexities one is that many tumors
have
lots of alterations in them tens of up
to tens of
thousands of these alterations in their
genome
some of them might be important for
driving cancer people call those driver
mutations
while others might not actually have any
effect they just happen to have gotten
mutated along the way and they don't do
anything
people call those passengers but in many
cases it's not clear
which alterations in different genes are
drivers or passengers
it's also the case that there are many
different genomic alterations
in different tumors so tumors from no
two patients will be identical
so there's a lot of complexity in trying
to understand which of those alterations
might be functionally important might
really be important for driving cancer
then not only is you know are these
tumors different but there's different
combinations of genes maybe one patient
has
you know these five genes another
patient has two of those but also three
or five others
so there's a lot of complexity there and
trying to understand
how these alterations in the genome of
cancer
cooperate to drive the
the way that cancer acts
so as you can imagine from these sort of
um
understanding of the genetics of human
cancer that
new tools that allow us to purposefully
alter the genome to ask questions of if
i create that mutation
that sometimes occurs in cancer does it
cause cancer does it help cancer grow
these are the type of questions that
these new tools can really help us
address
so the tool we're going to talk about
today is some crispr genome editing and
the example we use is crispr cas9 it's a
certain
um it was one of the first ones
discovered and it's sort of the
prototype for how this works these are
actually natural systems that occur in
bacteria
that now we can use um to better
understand
genetics the way these work in bacteria
is actually that
you can see on the left there's these
past genes these are crispr associated
genes these are proteins
that are encoded in bacteria naturally
and what these proteins do is they bind
to a small rna
molecule shown over here called a guide
rna
and when that protein and that rna
molecule come together then it can
actually help protect the bacteria
from these phage and phage are
essentially virus that infect bacteria
so this is a way that the bacteria can
defend itself essentially against these
these virus but what became clear is
that when you have
the ability to express a protein one of
these cast proteins
and this small rna called a guide rna
then if you can cut dna into bacteria
yes it's a phage
but if you could use it in mammalian
cells you could potentially cut
the dna um in a cell and and do
different things with it maybe create
mutations that we can then understand
how they function
so this is what people have done it ends
up that there's really only two
components that you need for this crispr
cas9 system you need this cas9 protein
and you need this small rna called a
guide on it
cas9 is a type of protein called the
nuclease in this case it means it can
cut
dna and the sgrna
is this rna molecule that can target
cas9 to anywhere in the genome
this rna molecule is actually the part
that binds to the dna
and specifies where it will bind and
it's what we call programmable you can
make it have any sequence you want and
when you make that guide already have a
certain sequence
it'll go to a certain region of the
genome and then cas9 will cut
the dna at that location and the reason
that's useful
is when you create a double strand break
in the dna
it then undergoes these natural repair
process just like our dna often does if
it gets
broken it can repair but that repair is
not always perfect
so you can get these small insertions
and deletions that then
essentially break that gene so we now
have the ability to express these two
components
cas9 and a guide rna create a double
strand break anywhere in the genome
that can be repaired and in some cases
it will inactivate that gene
so you can see now that we have the
ability to create these
alterations in the genome much like
those that
naturally occur in human cancer and i'll
tell you how we've been
using that to better understand how
essentially
cancer forms are one of the driving
forces so one key thing here that you'll
see in all of my examples is that you
need a guide rna
you need the casino protein you need to
somehow get that into the cells
and then we can look for the effects and
we can learn about what these genes were
in activating actually do
and also as you've probably seen i've
laid out a very complex
group of diseases the all these
different cancer types
and a genome editing tool that allows us
to start investigating how those genes
function
so this has really been sort of a
perfect match in the development of a
tool
and the ability to investigate a complex
disease
so the next thing i want to do is talk
about some applications of genome
editing
that have really accelerated our ability
to understand i think two
very important aspects of cancer
so the first thing that i want to talk
about is is not so much trying to say
hey these
genes are broken in cancer and we want
to break them and see what they do but
but rather present how people have been
using genome editing
to understand what we often call cancer
dependencies and this is saying you know
what do cancer cells really
need and if you could for example you
know inactivate a bunch of genes
um you might learn what cancer cells
depend on
and then that might be a route to
understand um how to
have drugs that can better kill cancer
cells i'll show you a few examples
and then the second main thing i want to
tell you about is really altering
genes of interest in uh
in cells to try to understand which of
those genes drive cancer growth and
different phenotypes different ways
those cells act
so first let's talk about uncovering
cancer dependencies
so what it laid out a few slides ago was
the idea that if you can get a guide rna
targeting a certain gene and
cas9 into a cell you can then inactivate
that gene and you can learn about what
it does so
in a very simple way you can imagine um
taking a cancer cell line these are
these are cells from human often
tumors that we can now grow um in dishes
in the lab and
you could take that cell line if you
express a guide rna targeting a certain
gene and cas9 you can you can
get a cell line that is essentially
identical to the initial one except that
it lacks maybe one gene that you think
might be important
and then and then we can look and see if
there's any effect on those cells and
what do the effect be
it could be that the cells all die that
seems like an important gene for cancer
cells
it could be that the cells grow slower
they could respond different to therapy
you know it could really be anything
that you know in the lab here we can
we can think about looking at and ask
questions about how does that
one gene function this is really the
basis of a lot of what we understand
about cancer a lot of what we understand
about biology is saying
how do we you know inactivate a gene and
then see what happens
you might imagine saying well if you can
delete one gene maybe you can
delete a lot of genes all at the same
time in different cells and you can
learn about what they all do
this has been um really a tremendous
application of crispr cas9 genome
editing saying
you know in this case let's take a
cancer cell line and you know we'll take
tens of millions of those cells and
and let's get it so that every cell has
a different guide rna expression you
know all these cells will inactivate
different genes we can then grow them
you know for a certain amount of time
and just ask the question of
you know what's the effect in this case
the effect could say if we inactivate
some of these genes
maybe this maybe this library that we
express actually inactivates all the
genes in the genome
but individual genes in different cells
if we grow them for some time
some of those cells will grow less well
and there's ways to understand that at
the end of the experiment to say oh
here's the hundred genes that really
hurt
these cancer cells oh here's some genes
that maybe help them grow
so these are the sort of applications
where you can start looking more broadly
at how different classes of genes impact
cancer growth or different
ways that they behave i'm using these
sort of cell line studies this has been
a huge application
i want to show one exact example from
one of my colleagues here mike basic i'm
in the gex department at stanford
where they took this one step further
further and said well we don't want to
just inactivate
one gene in these cancer cells or we
don't want to inactivate a bunch of
individual genes
they did an experiment to say if we
delete two genes in every cancer cell
um the cells grown in dishes in the lab
what will the outcome be and and the
prone thing here is that
which genes did they try to inactivate
as you know combinations as pairs and it
ends up that they decided to target
genes that are potential drug targets
so they have guide rnas that target
these potential drug targets and they
made
pairwise combinations of all these
different guide rnas to target
essentially pairs of drug targets
this is the layout of their sort of we
call them screens that they did where
they
you know have that one guide rna
targeting a drug target
another guide rna targeting another drug
target they made a huge number 21 000
different combinations of these
they can put them into this cancer cell
line and then all the pairs are
represented they grow them for some time
just like i said before and then
perhaps there's some pairs that now get
lost
from the sort of population of cancer
cells suggesting that inactivating those
two genes really hurts the cancer cells
this is a plot from their paper but the
important part to look at is really down
here
these are the pairs of genes that when
you inactivate them
really hurt this cancer cell line
and i want to highlight one which i'm
going to show a little bit on the next
slide but it says bcl2l1 and mcl1 these
are important proteins that normally
keep the cell alive but it appears that
if you
inactivate both of them here you really
have a huge impact on
probably killing these cancer cells
so the reason to do this whole
experiment
was there's a certain logic here that
says that if you can delete pairs of
genes using crispr
remember this is entirely impossible
without these sort of genome editing
tools
right if you can delete pairs of genes
maybe it tells you about pairs of drugs
that you should be using
because you identified those genes and
what they control as being important
in this genetic sort of screen that mike
basic's lab did
so then the next experiment they did was
to say well we now know which two genes
are important so what if we use two
drugs
that also inhibit essentially the
proteins that those genes make
and here's the result this is the
percent of cells that are dead
that's what the axis is showing and if
you have no drug there's very few dead
cells
if you have a drug that inhibits one of
these proteins you get a little bit of
death the other one a little bit of
cancer cell death
but if you inhibit both of them all of a
sudden you almost entirely kill the
cancer cells
so by doing this pair-wise
you know genome-editing screen they were
able to find
combinations of in this case drugs that
might be effective against this cancer
so these are some i think kind of uh
nice examples of how people have used
genome editing you know in very broad
scale right 20 000 genes 20 000
combinations
to really try to understand what do
cancer cells depend on
there's been huge efforts across you
know hundreds of different cancer cell
lines from
from different cancer types to
understand these sort of dependencies
as it might really help the development
of novel therapies
really really understanding how to hurt
cancers
so the next thing i want to talk about
is really using crispr cas9
genome editing to understand the driving
forces of cancer so yes cancers have
many mutations but which of these are
actually important in driving cancer
so one thing that i would like to point
out is that cancer
is really a complex process that occurs
within sort of the environment in which
the tumor is growing so
shown here on the left is a individual
normal cell
and this is what cancer comes from and
you know there can be
um certain genomic alterations these
changes that occur in those initial
cells
that drive the initial sort of expansion
of those cells and
maybe they're not behaving quite like
they're supposed to and then other
genomic alterations can occur
over time more of these mutations and
then the tumor gains a greater ability
to to grow there's also a lot of
interactions with other cells
i'm within the sort of micro environment
that tumor is and
this is one reason why we and others
have really focused on trying to
understand
cancer growth within in the in vivo
context right within the context of uh
of an animal that is growing these
tumors we think that some of these other
interactions are really critical
for understanding how cancer develops
remember i sort of told you that for at
least um crispr cast 9 genome editing
all you need is to be able to get the
guide rna in the cell
cas9 in the cell and you need some sort
of delivery method to get those two
things in there
so you can imagine being able to deliver
those to again that
single normal cell in our case within
mouse models of human cancer
and if you can get those into that
single cell you can then ask the
question okay does that
genomic alteration that you just created
now drive
early expansion of those cells drive
their bad behavior
allow them to grow particularly quickly
which would indicate that that gene is
important
in cancer
so we started doing this many years ago
and um the first cancer type that we
modeled using
um crispr cas9 genome editing within
these mouse models of human cancer is
actually pancreas cancer
and the way we did this is we had the
cas9 engineered within the mouse so the
so essentially every cell in the mouse
has the ability to express cas9
and then we could deliver the guide rna
component this programmable rna
um on a viral vector we use these very
frequently you can
engineer these virus to to do what you
want to just deliver in this
case this guide rna and one other
important component here
um and then we're able to deliver this
virus into the pancreas
of one of these mice and and start
asking questions about
how these certain genes may or may not
contribute to pancreas cancer growth
so we actually did this all in a model
for the aficionados where
all the cells will express uh an
oncogene called k ras and then we use
crispr
to alter other genes ask if they
normally suppress cancer growth
we also engineer these mice in a way
where all
the little tumors will glow red so in
this case this is a
pancreas from a mouse where all these
small red regions are these
oncogenic k-ras driven very very small
pancreas tumors but if we use crispr
cas9 genome editing to inactivate this
this gene that my lab cares about called
lkb1
it's a potential tumor suppressor but
what we found in the pancreas is if you
delete that gene
now rather than getting these really
tiny pancreas tumors you get these huge
pancreas tumors
this is clearly a gene that is
incredibly important
um in pancreas cancer when you delete it
you get bigger tumors
we can look at this a number of
different ways this is actually a
section
of a pancreas this is pretty much what a
normal pancreas looks like yours and
mine this is what it looks like
but now if you delete this gene using
crispr cas9 genome editing
in those cells within the pancreas or
this is not a cell line we're
transplanting we're actually genetically
altering
single cells within the pancreas of this
animal now we get
something that looks very different and
in fact this looks like
um some sort of variation of
human pancreas cancer the key feature
here is that what christopher cassini
and genome editing allowed us to do
is assess the importance of this gene
very quickly
there are other ways to do this they
would have taken us three four years to
do
but in this case we could do it in a
matter of months
so that for us is a huge advance that's
a huge advance for what our lab is able
to do and other labs are able to do as
far as understanding how these genes
impact cancer
growing in vivo
but i kind of started this talk by
telling you that cancer was very complex
many different genes are altered
many different combinations of genes are
altered and then i just showed an
example where
we went back and we deleted one gene and
we celebrated and we were happy but
how do we now start thinking about using
genome editing to understand more about
the complexity
so what i told you is certainly true if
this is sort of a
textbook model of cancer where there's a
single
normal cell that then gets an oncogene
and it
grows and these tumor suppressor genes
these genes that normally suppress
cancer growth are getting deleted
we can just look at human data and we
can say well lots of human cancers have
been
sequenced in this case i'm going to talk
about lung cancer
you can look at the frequency you know
what percent of human tumors have
inactivation of certain genes and
here's the ones we're going to talk
about sort of a list of 11 genes
and they're mutated at different
frequencies in human cancer and
some of our already genes that we know
are tumor suppressors and some of them
are not
and so we decided to try to develop a
system where
we could inactivate all 11 of these
genes in in different tumors but a way
where we could understand which of them
are important for driving
cancer so what i sort of showed you in
the pancreas we've also been able to do
in the lung and that would be to say
take a viral vector remember this is how
we're delivering the guide rnas to
inactivate this gene lkb1 that we like
so much
if you deliver that to the lung of a
mouse you can generate lung tumors if
it's a context or
it also has this oncogenic chaos and
that's fine
but what we decided to do was say well
what if we made a
pool of these lentiviral vectors these
viral vectors and
in each one we put a guide rna targeting
a different tumor suppressor
then if we delivered it to mice we can
actually develop in this case
you know 11 different flavors of tumors
we call them genotypes because they have
different genes mutated
11 different genotypes of tumors in an
individual mouse
then maybe we could just from one
experiment
assess how all for example 11 of these
genes might function
that's exactly what we're able to do we
can deliver this
pool of vectors to the mouse lung
we can generate all the different
genotypes each initial cell really only
gets one of these virus so
every tumor only deletes one of these
genes
and then we developed methods based on
high throughput sequencing to really
quantify the size of every single tumor
in the mouse maybe they get a thousand
we can quantify them all
we can understand how many cancer cells
they have and we can know
which of these 11 genes was inactivated
in each tumor
we could take that information and then
really try to understand the impact of
these genes but
even before we did that we knew that
some of the genes in here were really
important in driving cancer
this is actually the lung lobe from a
mouse and
this mouse does not have cas9 remember
when there's no cas9
none of those genes will be inactivated
and when there's oncogenic k-rash you
get some small little red tumors i hope
you can see here
when the mice do have cas9 and all those
tumor suppressors are being deleted in
individual tumors
now we saw many more large tumors
certainly some of these genes that we
activated are really important in
normally
slowing down growth and when we get rid
of them the tumors grow faster
so we analyze this in in many ways but
this is a sort of simple way to show it
where
the here all the genes we inactivated
and if they're dark blue it means if we
when we deleted them the tumors grew
really big
the ones that are lighter blue when we
deleted them the tumors grew a little
bit faster and
actually these white ones when we
deleted or
inactivated those genes it had no impact
on growth so that was also interesting
to us
so we could make some conclusions one is
that we actually identified
novel genes we've identified genes that
were not known before
to suppress cancer and in this sort of
pooled setting we could find those genes
was interesting to us that some of these
genes were
actually not important at least in
cancer how we had modeled it
and i would say that the effect of
inactivating different genes like
whether they had big effect or smaller
effect
it didn't correlate with how frequently
they're mutated in human cancer and the
reason we think this is important is
there may be genes that are altered in a
small
percent of human patients and in fact
those
genes are incredibly important in those
individual
tumors so we need these type of
approaches where we can look at large
numbers of genes
to really start looking at those that
are rare in human tumors but might still
be very important
but i also told you that remember it's
not in human cancer it's not a single
gene gets mutated there's going to be
combinations of genes that get mutated
so in human uh lung and carcinoma this
is the subtype that we're looking at i
showed you this before here is the
frequency at which
these genes are mutated these are the
ones that i just showed you the impact
of
but in fact if you say well there's this
gene p53 it's incredibly important see
here it's mutated almost half of lung
out of carcinoma
so if you look at human tumors that have
p33 mutations oh but they also have
mutations in
in all these other genes so there's
pairwise you know mutations in these
potential tumor suppressors and it's the
same if we look at another
subset of human lung cancer those that
mutate this gene called lkb1
they also have mutations in all these
genes so this is a sort of glimpse of
this
complexity i was talking about where
there's pairs of genes that are
inactivated
so we did another experiment where
instead of deleting one gene we deleted
the pairs and essentially created this
three by 11 matrix that i'm showing you
here
where we can then begin to understand
when you delete combinations of genes
what happens remember we don't want to
delete combinations of genes just for
fun
we want to understand when there's a
human tumor that has that pair
of genes inactivated is that in fact
working to drive the growth of the
tumor i think you can see that from the
sort of blue coloring that in some cases
when you delete pairs of genes the
tumors grow much better
than if they only had one gene to
activate
so it ends up that this comes to a
conclusion where we say
the effect of inactivating these genes
how genes drive
cancer it's really context dependent it
really depends on what other
genes have already been altered in the
tumor and this is something that wasn't
really previously
solidly established
so we've gone on with these type of
methods you know now to delete
50 putative tumor suppressors and start
looking at not only do they derive
growth which is kind of what i was
showing you before that's in the middle
but
you know do any of them drive tumor
initiation how well a cell will go from
being a normal cell to being a cancer
and then there's some other features of
cancer we've been able to look at but
we're starting to
develop more complex maps like this
where where some of these genes
you see this one in the top right called
pt10 it appears to be very important in
suppressing cancer initiation
and growth so when you get rid of it
there's more tumors and they grow faster
and other genes here have very different
phenotypes different
effects of deleting these genes so this
is really what we get excited about
because now we can start looking at
large numbers of genes
we can really understand what they do in
cancer growing in this case in these
mouse models
and the important thing to not forget is
the only reason we can do this is
because of the development
and discovery of crispr genome editing
right this
really easy way to inactivate
genes by just using cas9 and this guide
rna to target them
create dna breaks and ultimately
inactivate the genes
so i'd like to just talk about one last
thing which i think is tremendously
important
and this is the question of when you
have a population of patients
we actually now have widespread cancer
genotyping which means that
tumors from many patients are being
sequenced to find out which genes are
altered so
for many for example lung cancer
patients they come to the clinic and we
ultimately understand all the genes that
are mutated
there's also a lot of drugs as shown
here on the right
but one fundamental question that is
still
extremely hard to tackle is you know
which drugs should which patients get
these patients have different genes
altered and we have a lot of different
drugs but
you know which subset of patients should
get the red drug in which to get the
other drug
so we've tried to use our vivo
approaches to begin to address this
question
i told you that we can take this library
of viral vectors and we can initiate
tumors in mice that you know in this
case are essentially 12 different
genotypes 12 different flavors of tumors
so we did an experiment where we took
groups of mice with all those different
tumors
and we treated them with different
therapies then we did our same approach
to look at the size of every tumor
and this allows us now to start asking
questions about whether
they're the genes that are mutated in
the tumor
either make them more sensitive to
certain drugs that would be good
or more resistant to certain drugs well
that would also be good to know because
it would say
that if a patient for example has this
gene mutated
it should probably not be treated with
that drug the genotype of their tumor
will dictate their response and that
looks like maybe a genotype that won't
respond
so what we were able to do was create
sort of a map like this where
all the different genes that we
inactivated are shown on the left hand
side and the different drugs are shown
on the bottom
and i'm going to show you this sort of
heat map but what this really shows
is that any square that's red means that
tumors that had that gene inactivated
um were resistant to the drug
so for example you can well you can see
some of the dark red ones here right
that would mean that
if you inactivate that gene the tumors
really don't respond
then the blue squares mean that if you
have a tumor that has inactivated that
gene they're in fact very sensitive to
that drug so that would be good to know
and the interesting thing for us here
was not necessarily
the individual interactions between the
genes and the drugs
but that there were so many interactions
right so
these genes that we could inactivate
really drive drug responses and this
suggests
that the genotype of the tumor which of
these genes are altered
might be a major determinant of how well
patients tumors respond
um to different therapies and we would
love to think that you know these type
of findings can
can help with precision medicine right
understanding how the genotype of the
tumor
might dictate and drive which therapy
they'll respond best
so i'd like to end with some sort of
future directions where i see this going
at least in our line of work and then
some take-home messages so
um you know what aspects of cancer
development you know do we think
are poorly understood and where these
genome editing tools could develop
could help develop new understanding so
so this is sort of a drawing that some
of these people do of cancer
at the top is the cell the normal cell
the cancer came from and then as it goes
down
those sort of plus signs are new
mutations that occur
and and then sometimes it'll be you know
sort of different they call them
subclones but different pieces of the
tumor that are different from one
another and that's sort of these
different colors
so you can think about going from a
single normal cell all the way to the
bottom where you have a very
um heterogeneous tumor
so what do we still need to be able to
do better to understand cancer
um as you can see with these plus signs
these mutations that are occurring in
the cancer over time as it you know kind
of goes down the slide
it would be great to be able to control
when alterations occur so we
generate one mutation at the beginning
and then at later time points we can
introduce others that would be really
important in understanding sort of
cancer evolution
human cancer is still more complex than
what we're modeling within the mouse
in one level the mouse that we use these
type of models are actually very good we
can understand what genes do
but it might be nice to have system
develop even more complex alterations
like those that
occur in human cancer i talked a lot
today about
you know creating um alterations
in dna right these mutations or you know
these chromosomal changes but there's a
whole other layer
of complexity which is called
epigenetics this is where
genes get changed not by having
mutations but by other
elements that control their expressions
ways to use um genome editing to
understand epigenetics
these tumors as you can see here there's
a lot of different colors there's a lot
of complexity within an individual tumor
that's something that we would love to
be able to understand the meaning of
maybe the
different colored clones here sort of
helping each other that would be
interesting
and i think there's still a huge need to
better understand
how the genotype right how the genes
that are mutated
actually dictate therapeutic responses
to better
understand sort of precision medicine
type approaches
so with that i'll at my last slide here
of take home messages you know one is
that cancer is really a complex genetic
disease there's lots of genes that are
altered
and they drive the way cancer behaves
and this is important for us to
understand
second is that crispr based genome
editing
it really is accelerating our ability to
investigate
many different aspects of cancer
development from cancer initiation
growth metastasis drug response you know
every step along the way is
now kind of benefiting from being able
to do these types of experiments
and finally um i think that these type
of advances remember we went from
you know being able to inactivate one
gene to inactivate you know
in cells and culture 20 000 genes and in
the mouse
50 genes you know these are huge
advances and
i would love to think that some of these
approaches are going to be important
not only for understanding cancer but
thinking about how to treat it better
so thank you very much and i'll pass it
back over to jan
i want to start off by just actually
dr winslow can you speak a little bit
more about
the idea of crispr and gene editing
in somatic cells like you were talking
about versus
the germline mutations that we've seen
in the news and just kind of touch
on how your work is a little bit
different um
we don't need to go into the ethical
aspects of it but
if you could just touch on that a little
bit i think there's a few questions
about that
great thanks yeah so there's obviously
you know tremendous number of things
that can be done with
um crispr genome editing right and
what we hear a lot about is yeah this
the germline editing right altering
um you know organisms and and
but what we're really thinking about
here is is really separate from that
right we're really thinking about
using this technology to understand
right cancer so like i gave the example
where we have these cancer cell lines
here's just an experiment that we can do
within these cells to ask what do they
depend on what do they need to keep
growth
and then our our work within these
musculars and others
um is really um altering the genetics
in adult cells within these within these
organs where we want to understand
cancer so
so so these are quite different i would
say another another question that um
comes up quite often is you know the
thought that maybe we'll use crystal to
cure
cancer right if you can really delete
any gene you want you might think well
why don't we just get crispr into the
cancer cells and we can
we can we can cure it um it ends up that
this is
not an easy feat it's not easy to get
these guide rnas for example into every
cancer cell
um so really the two things i talked
about today were understanding
right um which cells are required in
cancers and then understanding the
genetics
of these um how we drive cancer
initiation and growth
great uh follow-up question to that is
actually
the would the same approach work for
diseases
other than cancer right
so um cancer is
if you want to just think about the best
application cancer would be the best
application because cancer is
a disease where mutations occur in adult
cells usually oh well usually and
usually over time
um and we can delete those genes or
alter them in different ways and then
look at cancer phenotypes
many other diseases are perhaps driven
by complex genetics but they're entirely
um but it's more the genetics of the
entire
organism or the entire person not
necessarily that a gene was altered
in an individual cell there are probably
other diseases like that but
um in in many cases i think there's
different approaches that could probably
be used better
in that regard so i would say that um
i guess i guess with that answer i was a
little bit stuck on thinking about the
the
vivo models that we use right but
actually there's
many applications of christopher
castaneda genome editing to understand
biology around other diseases
maybe taking um different cell types
like neurons or you know stem cells and
then
and then altering them with crispr and
then asking questions about what
different genes do
that's tremendously useful for
understanding what drives a lot of
different diseases actually so
there's a there's many different ways to
think about this but certainly
these general approaches could be used
to understand many different diseases
thanks great uh you mentioned that the
use of virus vectors to create an in
vivo
tumor growth uh can two different types
of tumors combine
so that they metastasize into a
genotypically altered third tumor
oh i see um yes right if two
tumors were or i think mostly we would
think about this slightly differently
i know in our models we generate a lot
of individual tumors like i said maybe
thousands of tumors
um it's certainly the case that for
example in human tumors
as they grow there's different mutations
in different cells even within the
growing tumor
so you end up with what we call
subclones you know kind of different
parts of the tumor that have different
genes altered
and it's certainly the case that
different subclones could perhaps help
each other and
maybe even help each other metastasize
so if that's the question then
it's entirely reasonable that that would
happen
um but very poorly understood how there
might be cooperation
um across different sub clones
i forgot that one right
if we use gene editing a gene editing
approach in cancer treatment
what are the challenges and limitations
that they'll be
and what are concerns for patients
yeah so the biggest challenge in using
crispr for actual cancer therapy
is that it's very difficult to get these
required components into all
cancer cells so you can't just say well
cancers need this gene and we're going
to somehow get cas9 and guide rna into
every single cancer cell it'll delete
that gene and the cancer will go away
you know there's too many cancer cells
this sort of delivering those things
is is at this point um not feasible
now you might imagine saying well what
if there was a way to get some crispr
cas9
you know guide rna components into only
one percent of cancer cells and then
for some reason if you kill that one
percent now
you have an impact on all the
surrounding cells maybe you activate the
immune system or you know something
like that there i think that's the way i
would think about it more which is
saying well
is there a clever way to not have to get
these components into all the cancer
cells
um and then the second part of the
question i think was sort of related to
what's the risk to the patient
um in
in a theoretical world where you could
do this i i wouldn't see them i mean
the risk is the same as any sort of
cancer therapy right
it's going to be side effects of having
impact on
normal cells um i don't think there'd be
a tremendously different risk for this
type of thing
now a lot of questions are actually
about the difference between
crispr and using like rnai methods and
so people were wondering
if you know what's what's more specific
in terms of you know knock down what is
better what are the pros and cons
um you know why is a crispr a better
technology for
what you're doing and being able to
knock down the genes
right okay so so rnai rna interference
is a very different type of method where
you express rnas
that bind to genes actually the mrnas of
genes and
and and reduce the expression so in in
that case
um and then of course you know crispr is
what i just talked about where you have
this cas9 or other protein and
nuclease and guide rna and you actually
cut the genome and you inactivate that
gene
um so they're very different for for two
reasons one is that
rnai is transient meaning that
when your rna molecule is there it will
reduce the expression of the gene but
over time it goes away
whereas crispr cast 9 genome editing
because you're actually altering the
genome
is stable so when you delete that gene
like we did in our models or in whatever
system
it will always be deleted from those
cells so that's one big difference
another difference is that when you
delete genes um
they're really gone they went from there
to zero
with rnai you're always knocking down
the genes meaning that you're reducing
the expression but probably not getting
it to zero
um so oh i think which method would be
better kind of depends on on what you
want to do right so in some of our
experimental settings we
really want to just inactivate that gene
have it be inactivated forever and see
what it does
there are different therapeutic
applications um where rna interference
is already being used
i mean even um you know to essentially
knock down
genes and help with disease phenotypes
so so they're very different um
approaches and they have different pros
and cons
um depending really on on what you're
trying to do yeah
it's very uh it's a very interesting
thing to think about how best to do it
experimentally or if you're thinking
therapeutically how best to do it that
way
thanks oh thank you
uh a couple other questions are asking
about you know this idea you're doing
this everything
in a mouse model how does that relate to
human you know
would the next step be ipc um stem cells
or would it be how yeah can you just
speak a little bit more about how mouse
models relate to
humans right yeah exactly so i mean i
think one key thing is
um what we start with is really human
data we start with an understanding of
the genes that are frequently mutated in
in human tumors in our case human lung
cancer and then
those are the alterations that we
engineer in the mouse lung epithelial
cells and then
and then look for how they do or do not
drive cancer um
so at that level you know the genetics
were sort of matching
um there's been studies to look at
you know sort of uh for example the what
does the tumor look like
if we take our tumors from the mouse
model and we show them to our pathology
colleagues here at stanford they'll tell
us oh yeah it looks like a subset of
human lung cancer so that that seems
good and
and we've done some other sort of
analysis on mouse tumors that appear to
align with with human lung cancer so
there's
several sort of analysis people have
done that that that give us faith that
these models are recapitulating at least
aspects of human cancer
i do think it's really important also
that these tumors in the in the mouse
models are
developing entirely you know in the
natural setting right from a single cell
all the way perhaps to a metastatic
cancer with
all the normal sort of interactions and
and this is a feature that
i mean i i do think them you know the
mouse is really
quite similar to human right lots of
what we understand about you know
disease biology developmental biology
has come from the mouse
um so we do think about this but uh i i
think it's a pretty
actually um parallel system to the human
but a system where we can control things
right we can delete
genes and we can ask what they do and we
can give therapies and you know see what
happens so
okay great and then one last question um
a few people were interested in in how
you're actually getting
crispr and the guide rnas into the cells
um so it's more a little bit more of a
technical question but if you could just
expand on how that process happens in
the lab
oh yeah right so for the approaches that
i showed where we have these mouse
models of human cancer
um we actually have the the mice
are engineered in a way where they have
the ability to express cas9
in any cell that we need it so so that's
actually within the germline of the
mouse and there's these
strains of mice that that have the
ability that so cast nine is within the
mouse and then
and and then the way we deliver the um
the guide rnas and other things that we
want is is through these viral vectors
so
the reason i don't call them viruses you
know virus can replicate and you know
we all know that problems um these are
essentially you know
engineered viral vectors meaning they
kind of are like a virus and they can
deliver something to a cell
but they can never they can never
replicate so
people use this a lot experimentally to
essentially get things into cells and
and we use this type of um virus called
the lentivirus but essentially just as a
as a vector to take what we want and
then get it into the cell so that that's
how
we do it i would say across many
different systems there's lots of lots
of different ways to do it
um so for example we all know that you
can package mrna
in in lipid nanoparticles now and you
can deliver it to cells that's how the
physical vaccines work right so
um there are different ways to get what
you want into cells and then
yeah exactly slightly different in vivo
and in style culture but
there's lots of methods that probably
depends what you want to do
great thanks oh thank you and
if you would like to learn more from dr
winslow and the rest of the genetics
faculty
we encourage you to join our genetics
and genomics program
you will have more than 90 hours of
content to learn from
and as well as access to videos
exercises
and other types of activities that will
really help you sharpen your skills
once again thank you for joining us
today we hope you have a great
weekend and we hope to see you again in
future
sessions
you